flexo our next bootcamp lectures are
from a payaso of UC San Diego he's an
authority on many subjects which is the
randomization from circular valves that
he will be talking so someone wants to
find remarrying your your ex as the
triumph of Hope over experience
my plan for today's talks is probably
another trots I triumph so the plan is
to talk about D randomization based on
specific lower bound techniques for an
hour and namely the proverb and proof of
the the Nissan the Neil conjecture and
then in the second hour talk about
generic connections between hardness and
between lower bounds and Albert and D
randomization so um so I thought I
wanted to start with a kind of
motivating example of an algorithm that
we might want to do randomized okay
where that was the randomized
successfully so this is um Mike bluebies
parallel maximal independence at
algorithm so or simplification there up
okay so um so independent set in a graph
is a set of vertices no two of which is
connected its maximal if you can't add
another vertex or equivalently if every
vertex not in the set has a neighbor in
the set so on so now if you just want to
solve this problem finding a maximal as
opposed to maximum size independence
that is trivial you just pick any vertex
remove its neighbors and you keep on
going the problem is that's an
inherently sequential process and what I
mean inherently sequential what I mean
is Steve cook showed that it's actually
P complete to define the lock so
graphically first
independent set so um my Clube actually
this was his simplified up parallel
algorithms to find a maximal independent
set there was there was previous work
giving some parallel algorithms worth
and that he had a sub procedure where
you found a big independent set that
covered lots of vertices and then you
just applied this procedure many times
so that I'm assuming totally unrealistic
lis that the graph is d regular meaning
every node has D exactly D neighbors and
then the algorithm becomes for every
vertex you put it in some set J that's
like a tentative independent set with
probability 1 and for D ok now we don't
control whether you know still possible
that two neighbors are in the
independent set and it's not an
independent set at all so if there's if
if B has a neighbor also in the in the
tentative independent set you delete
both of them from the independent set so
and then you you put K in the things
that remain in jr. in the independent
set and we can forget about anything
that's a neighbor of one of them because
they're covered they'll never be in the
independent set and then we recurse on
the rest of the graph and the object is
to to make the rest of the graph as
small as possible show that we're making
off the progress so the main factor K
the J is going to be relatively small
the main factor that we could hope to
simplify the graph is the number of
neighbors subject we can write out a
formula for the numbers of neighbors of
K in terms of the the bits that tell us
whether we we put something initially in
J or not so well so it's like for every
I is a isn't in jfe is it covered by
something in J well if it's covered by
something in here we can count it by the
first neighbor of I that lands in J well
so we can sum up over all neighbors of
gay that it's the first neighbor so what
does it mean to be the first neighbor
that still stays in J first we have to
near
surely it has to be NJ and it can't
there can't be anything earlier that
appeared enjoy now we'll be a little bit
pessimistic and say okay well to be in J
at the end you first have to be in J at
the beginning and you can't have any
neighbour of yourself inject the other
thing is to be the first one we'll just
assume that you're the first one that
was flipped not necessarily the first
one that ends up so you could be not the
first one this flip but still be the
first one that ends up in the set both
so we're being a little bit pessimistic
here but as an upper but a lower bound
we can subtract off just the probability
that you're in the set initially in
something earlier is in the set
initially they now you see okay now it's
easy to compute the expectation of this
quantity because what do we have we have
a sum over N Things a sum over D things
of a coin flip of probability one in 4d
and then we're subtracting off at most D
things here of the of the form sum this
probability squared and D things here of
the form that's probability squared so
we get that the expected number is at
least n times D times 1 in 4d the
probability of putting something in
minus the probability of putting tooth
to D chances about putting two things in
so 2 D over 16 T squared and so we end
up with something like n over 8 so we
get rid of a constant factor of the
graph each iteration and so we expect to
have only log iterations now Mike show
the reason I wrote it out exactly in
this formula is what kind of expression
is this formula is a degree 2 polynomial
and the degree 2 polynomial only
involves interactions between pairs of
random random outcomes and so that means
that we don't actually need randomness
for this
what we need is pairwise randomness any
kind of distribution where pairs of
variables have the the right this right
marginal distribution we can sample from
a pairwise independent distribution with
support and squared and we can enumerate
the support in time N squared and and we
can do this in parallel and try them all
and pick the one that's best so and like
had some idea that were more clever than
this but but I won't go into those so so
that's kind of like the general spirit
of D randomization is you're given
randomized algorithm you try to think of
it as a family of described so their
algorithm has its real input and its
random choices and you think a prefixed
real input you think of a test about
randomness if that's what happens when
you run that algorithm with that input
on a random string and what we want is
to find a distribution this is Gibbs
even if we have just one algorithm this
gives a class of tests and often we're
not only have one algorithm that we're
looking at but a whole class of
algorithms and so we want to find a
distribution that fools all this the the
entire class of test in other words
where the expectation on the
distribution of any test in the class is
very close to the expectation on a
random distribution and one just some
notation that I'm going to use is if we
have a boolean function or even a real
valued function and a distribution I'm
just going to write T of that
distribution to mean the expected value
when we pick an input from the
distribution of of the function and this
just saves just saves a few a few lines
few symbols every time but symbols that
are going to appear so often that
saving a constant factor makes a
difference so when we have such a
distribution we could we do what might
get we go through all the the random
strains that are in the support of the
distribution and we've run the algorithm
in parallel or sequentially or however
we want free such for such support in
place of the randomness and then we use
the majority or best answer or whatever
is appropriate to the problem and so the
important thing here is that it's really
important that the support of our
distribution be really small because
we're going to be exhaustively searching
that support it's kind of mildly
important that we can generate we can
generate the elements of the support in
about the same amount of time so the
most important thing is small support or
compression the somewhat important thing
is efficient generation and I just want
to say that and both of these are very
likely to be small but comparable but a
little bit larger than the resources of
the algorithm we're trying to pull so
okay and the reason I want to say that
make a point of that is that there's a
dual there's another application
besides the randomization for pseudo
randomness and that's in cryptography in
cryptography if you're using a
pseudo-random generator to generate
seeming randomness that you're going to
use for cryptographic applications to
pick your cryptographic keys to or none
says for for padding your your input for
probabilistic encryption it's you know
important mildly important but you know
is it is that it's important but not the
most important thing that the the way
you want to save randomness so you want
to use fewer
random bits then then you're generating
a pseudo-random generator that uses more
randomness that it's outputting is not a
very good pseudo-random generator so
this and so the support of D must be
non-trivial much less than 2 to the N
okay but what's really important is that
the time to sample from this
distribution has to be much smaller than
the time that we're trying to fool the
resources that we're trying to fool so
the resources of sample have to be some
here smaller here they just have the
time to sample just doesn't have has to
be not a huge amount bigger okay and so
the kind of results that you get for you
in the cryptographic setting the
assumptions that you need for
pseudo-random generators are really
different from the assumptions that
suffice and look different and stronger
than the assumptions that suffice in the
D randomization setting for that reason
I prefer I try to only call
pseudo-random generators the
cryptographic side and just called this
side pseudo-random distributions I don't
promise to totally stick to that because
I'm fighting history ok but on the other
hand a lot of the fundamental work that
went into studying pseudo randomness in
the cryptographic setting by people like
Hugh Mir Blum Macaulay Yau and others
transports over some of it transports
over and some of it doesn't
and you so you have to be a little bit
careful but a lot of there's a lot of
reuse of the cryptographic approach
which actually came a little bit earlier
it's important but it's it's not as
important as on this side yes there's ok
was a somewhat important because it's
usually pretty easy to get to it here
because the standard is kind of relaxed
it's not so hard to achieve
okay still it's still important it's
just this is the most important and here
this is still important but this is the
most important so maybe actually just
removed somewhat and just like most
important also important okay so the
interesting thing about or one of the
interesting things about using lower
bounds to 2d randomize so we said when
we phrase it in terms of finding a
distribution that pulls a test we're
freezing it in terms of the distribution
poses a hard problem to the class of two
the amount of resources that the tests
are from to the class that the test is
from the hard problem being tell the
difference be is this real randomness or
is this pseudo randomness so that's a
hard problem and so that's their kind
the connection between having hard lower
bounds and D random supers constructing
pseudo-random distributions and then
coming up with algorithms that
deterministically simulate randomized
algorithm so the whole process forms one
of the fall crumbs in complexity where
were able to change direction we're
proving a stronger lower bound moving
the lower bound up moves the upper bound
down and Ryan was talking about some
approaches on the other side we're
moving the upper bound down increase the
lower bound and if you look inside his
approaches you'll see this full Trump
there's like a few changes of direction
so once you've got a few a few of these
operating in multiple directions you
have like a whole machinery
you can put together okay
so
[Music]
okay I think I just erased is what I
want to talk about now okay
the
the first the first kind of class to the
but what I want to talk about as a first
example is started as a life as an asan
linic lineal conjecture became the bra
verben theorem and then actually I just
learned this today
maybe we'll have time to talk about the
the towel improvement to the proper myth
there and this actually been this is
related to what Ben was talking about
yesterday afternoon
what what and so like so what been
started talking about is a so we have
this class AC zero okay and I'm gonna
have to beg to differ with papel AC zero
is a really important class and not just
a surrogate for what were we where we've
been going so AC zero represents what
you can do in constant parallel time
unnatural architectures it's also
logically important because it's it's
the non-uniform version of first-order
and because also because because it
represents constant parallel time very
fast parallel time this is an
appropriate appropriate model for
hardware implementations an appropriate
model possibly for things happening
inside our brain so as you like visual
processing where we have to recognize
things really quickly or else be eaten
by Tigers okay but maybe maybe that's
like TC 0 rather than a few zero in the
brain so um you think you think we
wouldn't recognize the tiger if any of
us okay
so so anyway the the Looby algorithm was
the closest I could think of to a
natural randomized ac0 algorithm but um
so what we'll show is that generalizing
that that instead of pairwise
independence
the size independence fools hd0
in other words any is generalizing
pairwise to poly log wise independence
where the bits are any poly log Watts
size collection of its looks in this is
marginally uniformly distributed creates
a distribution that's suitable for D
randomizing any algorithm in in this
class AC zero that been talked about
yesterday
I think it's been talked about enough
that I won't define AC zero so and sort
of the connection is already kind of
clear from what been the kind of
intuition it's kind of clear from what
Ben was saying yesterday because what
what the random restriction methods tell
us
is that an AC zero formula F it's kind
of close to a decision tree you know
it's once you like do anything to it it
becomes a kind of small depth decision
tree
and a deputy decision tree is a depth is
it you can write it directly as a degree
D polynomial
and G why's independence just as we as
we argued with luby's algorithm
perfectly fools degree D polynomials in
that the expectation isn't just close
it's exactly the same because of
linearity of expectations each term
involves at most D variables the D
variables are identically distributed
and so the the total expectation of any
polynomial is the same under any D wives
independent distribution including the
uniform distribution over the reals yes
so then I'm not sure what additivity of
it if a Nativity of expectations really
works mod - I mean this this came up
last last week when I was talking about
this and I still had the same answer so
if someone can like define a virtual mod
- that would be really really good so um
yes the problem is when you're talking
about the expectation I mean the
distinguishing that this that's why my
two doesn't work well well when you have
a polynomial mod - okay usually what you
mean by representing a function is that
say 99% of the time it's equal to the
function ma - how do you make that into
an expectation ma - okay so the 1% of
the time where it fails is that even
what percent of the time we're an odd 1%
of the time the fact that it's just 1%
doesn't help us with that did you not
define distinguishability was like the
probability they distinguish or XY
look at that guy but then I think that
doesn't help but so I'll leave that as a
challenge I'm not even going to say it's
an open problem because I don't know how
to define it but to come up with any
version that that makes sense over a
finite field I think that would be
interesting
so so right now we have to like keep it
just respect the fact that and Bates was
party's permission to be one of n minus
one independent I think
oh you think so here's like a
counterexample yeah think so like you
can if you look at all inputs whose
parody is zero its n minus one
independent but it certainly doesn't
full parody even though parody is a very
small degree polynomial odd to that what
you were saying yeah okay
so so we want some senses in which we
want to formalize this connection a
little bit more so try to say that a
function in AC zero can be represented
by by a polynomial over the real numbers
represented or approximated and hence
that that means that D wise independence
is going to fool that AC zero because
it's going to fool the approximating
polynomial and we're going to see a
couple of ways to do this approximation
and the clever part of bra vermin's
argument is that he both of these ways
don't work to do what i just said but if
you combine them cleverly he was able to
get them to work
so the first sense in which we can
approximate a polynomial in AC zero is
is dates back to two lineaments or anise
on
you showed that there's the AC zero
functions have fourier concentration and
I'm gonna define what this is so so to
do this we're gonna do a little bit of a
shift by a little bit of a shift I mean
a linear transformations so instead of
like thinking of the boolean inputs at 0
1
we're temporarily going to think of of 0
as 1 & 1 is minus 1 so look at minus 1 2
this bit and the advantage is now that
the parity function goes to the product
and these products become an orthogonal
basis in the in the following sense if
we define an inner product between two
functions as the expectation of f of X
times G of X for random acts
any two parodies to parody functions to
stink parody functions have expectations
zero because see the X I squares just
become one the parts where there have in
common
disappeared the parts where they're
different have degree one and they're
just as likely to be one and minus one
fixing the others so they just cancelled
so this forms a northern up or
orthonormal basis and so on we can write
any function in terms of this basis so
when we do that we write f as a sum
alpha s where s is a subset of 1 to n of
the product i n s of X V
and now it's actually easy to see that
these alphas have a have an intuitive
definition they're just
the correlation of the function with the
corresponding parity
this makes sense so it's also true
because of the north of normal
transformation and because F is now 1 or
minus 1 so we're also thinking about as
taking values 1 and minus 1 f l2 norm is
just 1 because F squared is always 1 and
that means the same thing is true when
you write it in this representation so
the sum of alpha ves squared is just 1
are you sorry means you can sort of like
think of these alpha the coefficient
squared as a kind of probability
distribution you see ok where is the
mass of that distribution where is it
concentrated and what they showed is
that the mass of the distribution is on
is on sets that are small almost all
for a mess
is on sets s where the size of s this
one let me try to make that a little bit
more precise
I'll also try to give up
if app has a depth pea-sized s circuit
then the sum of all ask so that size of
S is greater than water log s over
epsilon to the T and there's some
constant here
so all of this the constant also gets
raised to the deep alphabet squared
okay in what I just found out I've been
talking and confirmed with Avishai is
that there's actually been an
improvement that's going to actually
make a difference later on an
improvement is a little bit subtle
so you can instead of having the s and
the epsilon be treated equally in this
hopefully I'm getting this right yes
maybe the D plus 1 by Q plus 1 okay
totally like both of them no no okay D
minus 1 or is it because yeah okay I'm
gonna ignore that but this is this is
right right okay so that means that we
can actually improve it and you get the
same consequence so that's a fairly big
improvement when we want a very small
approximating error and have a fixed
size
okay but I'm gonna I'm gonna give the
original element argument because I
don't know this one baby I wish I will
give it some other time okay
so on
so let's see what happens to those
Fourier coefficients so we want to look
what happen so hoping we understand is
what happens to two AC zero functions
under random restrictions let's see what
happens to to the Fourier expansion
under restrictions and now to make it
simple let's look at what happens to the
Fourier coefficient coefficients when
you just restrict by one variable okay
which one do I want to use blue so um so
we have like the original function is
1/2 of s
f of X is the sum of this alpha forty
coefficients times these products
so let's look at what happens when the
first variable gets one in the first
variable gets -1 well just look at plug
that into this formula and this is going
to be like
some over a subset of 2 through n say
we're combining the terms that have s as
the subset for the other variables and
either have an X 1 in them or not so win
it ok so when it doesn't have X 1 in it
I'll put a 0 here that doesn't change
because the value of x 1 is irrelevant
here we're plugging in X 1 equals 1 so
we add in the coefficient of s Union X 1
so the new Fourier coefficient is the
Sun this is the same except what do you
think the new for Fourier coefficients
- okay and then the nice thing is let's
look at what happens okay and this
happens with probability 1/2
this happens with probability 1/2 so
let's look at the average square of the
Fourier coefficient well you get 1/2 of
this squared you get this squared plus
twice the inner the product plus this
squared same thing except - so you get
two squares and then each one in half so
so that means the expectation of you
know alpha of s is the expectation of
alpha prime of s when we do the squared
is a alpha of s Union 1 squared plus
alpha so these two just sort of move
over an expectation to this one so
things just move down proportionally the
math doesn't really change the length of
the vector doesn't really change it just
moves over so um okay so what's gonna
happen when we do a random restriction
with multiple variables what that means
is that if we've got a term alpha best
product I n s X I then its mass and
expectation we just think of which bear
you pick at random the variables were
going to leave as stars and we're going
to set the others at random its mass
alpha squared becomes the gets moved
down in expectation to ass intersect row
inverse of star
your place assistant so in particular if
this starts at if we start with
something of size T then and and bro is
picked leaving from the distribution RP
then we expect this to move to about
suicide of size P times T
so so that means if we restrict with
probability P the mass that was at size
T moves down in expectation to size PT
on the other hand what's going to happen
if we get us if it becomes a small
decision tree then the high degree terms
just disappear because there's just one
way of writing this is upon as a multi
linear polynomial and there you know you
can write it in terms of the depth of
the decision tree so that part just
disappears so the only way that we we
could have this mass moving into the
small parts and and yet the small the
started to the the large mass move into
the medium-sized mass and the
medium-sized mass doesn't exist with
high probability if there were very many
large mess the large mass was small to
begin with so okay so I could try to
spell that out but but since I have so
little time I won't I think unless
there's mass rebellion at this point
okay so to get the conclusion we need
the switch we say I said the okay okay
so maybe I will spell it out
okay so what we know is if we pick P to
be 1 in log s over epsilon to the D
minus 1 and this is like so like then
the probability that F restricted by Rho
that the decision tree is greater or
equal to this log s over epsilon is less
than collapse
and that's that's exactly what the the
multiple layers of the switching Lama
said okay so if you combine it with this
if you say okay that means the expec the
expected part
for the expectation over of alphabet
squared our Apple prime of s squared
when F prime equals F restricted by row
when s is greater equal to this log s
over Epsilon
is a most episode
because okay so why is this true well if
this Hut if the decision tree unless
this happens this is zero and even if it
doesn't happen we know though all the
squares are one so the the the squares
that we're counting are at most one so
probably epsilon we get something at
most one with other otherwise we get
exactly zero yes you've got two meetings
of Esther the subset for the subscript
this is a little s oh that's a little
less sure yeah okay the matter of
perspective okay so so so and on the
other hand we said that this is also
this expectation is is greater than or
equal to the sum over all sets where s
is greater equal to
it's log s over epsilon over P which
works out to about this of the original
for EAMS because all of these set all
this for DMS ends up in this in this
region with good probability and I'm
cheating there's like a factor of two
but who cares
so so that means that in the original
distribution the large Fourier
coefficients were smaller than epsilon
and this improvement is by sort of like
here we were like being very symmetrical
and how we're treating the epsilon and
the absent making sure we're doing a
union bound at every step and I think
like the new multi switching lemmas
allow you to kind of do a finer
distinction between the dependence on s
and the dependence in s
okay
so that's one sense in which we can
approximate so I should say how what in
what sense is this a good approximation
of the original function
so if we let F be the original function
and have Tilda be the part of the
original function where s is less than
this degree
this degree bound that we get over here
this is no longer a boolean function
it's a real valued function but I'm
saying saying it's very close to have
why because we know the part that we're
leaving out the sum of the alpha squares
is at most Epsilon but that means that
the in other words what that's saying is
that the l2 norm squared of the
difference of these functions is the
part that we left out in that that part
is less than Epsilon so since the l2
norm is saying when you look at the
Fourier basis as it is when you look at
the value basis this is saying the
expectation of f of X minus F tilde of X
180 squared is in those
give a couple of consequences of this
because the expectation of a square is
always bigger than the square of an
expectation it follows that the
expectation of the absolute value is a
most square root of epsilon and here's
something that's a little bit less less
obvious the expectation of the
difference of the squares
isn't most order square root of Epsilon
okay I think maybe I'll work this out
this is this takes like a little bit of
calculation but not too much so this is
this is a same s f of X minus F tilde
out of X value times f of X plus F tilde
X
okay and now I'm going to do a something
a little bit cheap I don't know what F
tilde is but I know F has absolute value
one it's not too tuned to huge so I'm
going to write this as
expectation of F of X minus F tilde of x
times two f of X plus F tilde of X minus
f of X
and then use a triangle inequality say
this is at most two times the
expectation of the difference
plus the expectation of the difference
180 square
and we already have this last and square
root of epsilon in this less than
Epsilon
so so these these three senses are in
with our senses in which this function
is a low degree function that's a good
approximation to our original function
so let me give another kind of
approximation and it's very similar to
this other approximation is very similar
in spirit to the Roth Roth Smolenski
approach to proving lower bounds over
finite fields so we're going to work our
way up from the bottom and come up with
a polynomial that usually equals our
function so
so remember or if you don't know the the
the point is to like approximate the the
circuit gate by Kate in Ross Ross
Polanski what they do is they they say
we're like approximating it by a low
degree polynomial ma - we pick random
ours and we take these inputs and we
think okay let's look at some of our ixi
if all of these are 0 this is always
zero if any of them is 1 this is 1 with
probability 1/2 so they like do this a
number of times
Monte not - right
in update a some tea
and take the or with pretty good
probability this is actually the or okay
it's probably except for my two to the
minus T we won't do the same thing over
the real numbers we can't do ma - but
here's and if we just pick these are
eyes at random and there lots of excise
the chance of here we want to like say
exactly one versus zero fortunately
valiant and Boz irani
showed that there is a distribution over
subsets J subset of 1 0 n so that for
any non-empty Hey
the probability that the size of a
intersect K equals 1
is at least one in Lockett so if we
think of apply this then they gave a
very nice construction we don't need
that the main idea is just to sort of
guess how dense this the satay is how
big the settee is and then pick a
probability inversely proportional to
the density so you expect to have about
one so you have to like make sure you
pick all kinds of range of sizes which
is where the log comes in but they gave
a very nice explicit construction okay
so if we do this what we'll do is like
look at the product of the some pick
many samples from this distribution
and what
so we'll just this tea times and look at
this product now what happens or maybe I
should put up plus one and minus one
here so if all the X gays are zero we
always get one if any of them are
nonzero because of this property with
good probability about one in login we
get we get the value zero so this is you
know one one minus this is going to be a
good representation of the or function
meaning almost always equal to the or
function so so here the error
probability is 1 minus order of log N or
log of the fair nin which is the most
one in log of the circuit size to the T
is our probability of error which is
exponential and negative T over order
log s so we need to make T bigger than
so we need to make T equal to like vlog
epsilon over s to make sure we can do a
Union bound at the end yes one of those
others times log
so so we could upper we could found it
by just the log squared so so this gives
a probabilistic polynomial that I'll
call little app that's representing our
function big f and little F has the
property that if I use these parameters
the probability that little F is
different from big f is at most Epsilon
and the degree of little F well we have
to use this value of T and that means
that we like raised the previous degrees
to the teeth power at every depth so the
degree of F is going to be T to the D
which is like order log s over epsilon
to the Judy what the probability is over
the random choices of these hence the
choice of little a little J's so we
picked gaze from this value involves
Errani construction and maybe they work
and maybe they don't right and so this
is large that the function little F is
identical to the function capital F
right so it's identical except when when
one of these fails when one of these we
accept with probability Epsilon
the thing is when it's not identical it
can be way off
it's say for every for every X you pick
something random and then the
probability that X yeah
so this so the nice thing is that this
is true not just under the uniform
distribution but on any distribution
because we're doing this probabilistic
construction on each input you can think
of it the same just you know same
distribution input by input so
so here we have that the the probability
that f is different from f is lessening
Epsilon but when f is different from at
that is not boolean and could take a
value up to the size of the circuit to T
to the D is like to to the log to the
log s over epsilon 2
so when when when f is wrong it's very
very wrong so when I presented this in
class someone reminded me of the of the
nursery rhyme about the girl with the
curl that when she was good she was very
very good but when she was bad she was
horrid so so when the function is good
which is most of the time is very very
good but when it's bad is horrid the
nice nice thing is that this holds under
any distribution
unlike the Fourier approximation that
only is close to the function under the
uniform distribution okay so I think I
will be I will tone down my ambitions
and maybe not get to the general generic
case and just continue this after the
break because sort of like receives like
we're finally getting somewhere
so so why don't we take the break now
and then like try to put these pieces
together after the break